حسبي الله
ونعم على باب قصف من طائرات
الاحتلال هدفنا في هذه المنطقه بالقرب من
المستشفى الميدان الاردني تم استهداف على
ما يبد مننزل في هذا المكان هناك عدد من
الشهداء
والاصابات
المكان حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل ايش اللي
صار يا حجه ايش في ونعم
الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم
[موسيقى]
الوكيل حسبي الله
ونعم
كويسين احمد مات احمد
[تصفيق]
مات
ادنا
ياسد يا عالم يا عرب ح ودنا يا عرب يا
محمد يا رسول
[تصفيق]
اللهد
يا
مره حده ايش صش شفتيه لا انا كنت ماش من ه
صاروخ زن كان قاعدين مع بعض انضربوا كلهم
دار وا كانوا سبعه اللي قاعدين بس استشهد
ست كان في واحد ش
مصاب كنت ماشيه من
هنا يعني هذا المكان استهداف هذا المكان
تجمع للمواطنين من عائله وادي هذه اشلاء
بعض الشهداء
والمصابين
افتح على الارض على
الض اشلاء بعض الشهداء بعد عمليه قصف قامت
بها طائرات الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه لمجموعه
من المواطنين في هذا المحيط الى الشرق من
مستشفى ناصر وبقرب ايضا من المستشفى
الميدان الاردني هنا في هذه المنطقه
وتشاهدون
الدماء على هذه الارض بعد استهداف بشكل
مباشر من قبل طائرات الاستطلاع
الاسرائيليه لمجموعه من المواطنين في هذه
المنطقه وادى الى ارتقاء عدد من الشهداء
واصابه عدد اخر في هذا المكان هذه اثار
الصاروخ صاروخ الاطلاع الذي اطلقته طائرات
الاطلاع الاسرائيليه في هذا المكان وهذه
اثار دماء دماء الشهداء والمصابين نتيجه
عمليه القصف التي تمت قبل
قليل
حطه حطه حطه من البنطلون من هذا
حطه